[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to our installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the four hogwarts houses
gryffindor slytherin ravenclaw and
hufflepuff
in relation to the evil witch and wizard
population
more specifically we will be discussing
whether or not death eaters
have ever come from a house other than
slytherin hagrid once remarked to harry
better hufflepuff than slytherin said
hagrid darkly
there's not a single witch or wizard who
went bad who wasn't in slytherin
you know who was one and as far as dark
witches and wizards go
the worst kinds were death eaters
followers of lord voldemort who obeyed
his bidding in an effort to
cleanse the wizarding world the death
eaters were a group of pure blood
radical supremacists
ever bloodthirsty and always more than
eager to incite fear
in the hearts of their enemies the death
eaters were originally formed
while a young tom riddle attended
hogwarts between 1938
and 1945 but at that point they were not
yet known
as death eaters they were called the
knights of alpergus
the knights of war pergus was a group
formed by slytherin students
exclusively as many of their core goals
and perspectives
as a group coincided with the beliefs of
slytherin house
these students were certainly a bit
morally dubious and dumbledore once
described riddle's gang
as a mixture of the weak seeking
protection the ambitious seeking glory
and the thuggish seeking a leader who
could show the more refined cruelty
the key phrase that sticks out to me
here is the ambitious seeking glory
as i feel that this almost directly
resonates with one of the key
characteristics
involved with being a slytherin student
core aspects of each of the four houses
can be very broadly summed up in
assorted cat's own words
which are as follows by gryffindor the
bravest were
prized far beyond the rest for ravenclaw
the cleverest
would always be the best for hufflepuff
hard workers were
most worthy of admission and
power-hungry southern loved those of
great ambition
ambition great ambition this is the
characteristic
that i feel best addresses the core
similarities between southern students
and death eaters and this is why i think
that so many death eaters ended up
coming
from slytherin it's not that students
from other houses aren't ambitious
it's just that ambition is extremely
closely routed to the very
existence of students that end up
getting sorted there one thing that i
feel should be addressed
however is that ambition isn't bad i
know that the connections to slytherin
and the death eaters sort of make it
feel that way but ambition is a
wonderful thing if the right person
possesses
it another thing that i feel needs to be
mentioned is that slytherin students
aren't inherently bad or evil yes one of
their core characteristics
matches one of the core characteristics
of the death eaters
but there are also plenty of slytherins
that never turned evil
most of their bad rep comes from founder
salazaren's perspective
on muggleborns and half-bloods when he
founded the house
salazar satherin imbued the belief in
his students that muggle-borns and
half-bloods
were not worthy of practicing magic his
perspective made an impression on
some of but not all of the students of
his house
and the poisonous ideologies that he
introduced was subsequently passed on
from generation
to generation ron once remarked i always
knew zelazar slytherin was a twisted old
loony
but i never knew he started all of this
pureblood stuff i wouldn't be in his
house if he paid me
honestly if the sorting had to try to
put me in slytherin
i'd have got the train straight back
home but in truth
slytherins aren't always just the
one-dimensional evil villains they're
always painted out to be
the house is comprised of all sorts of
complex characters that are far more
deserving of a label
that isn't just evil slytherins are
often very clever
very resourceful and very determined but
in dumbledore's own words usually also
possess a certain disregard for the
rules
in addition to the above qualities they
are also often very strong leaders
as shown with tom riddle and even
celeste otherin himself
i think that one of the main issues with
the house however is that it does sort
of foster pure blood supremacist ideals
to some degree
and this is perhaps why it ends up
producing the largest amounts of dark
witches and wizards
when compared with the other houses with
all that being said
there are a lot of death eaters so
surely some of them must have come from
other houses right the obvious exception
to a death eater that came from another
house is of course peter pettigrew
as mentioned in the title one important
detail worth mentioning
however is that peter pettigrew was a
hat stool meaning that
he very nearly ended up in sutherland a
hat stool is a very rare event
and it occurs when during the sorting
ceremony the hat needs additional time
to come up with a decision
it occurs when a student has a
personality that could be considered
equally suitable for multiple hogwarts
houses
in pettigrew's case the very rare hat
stool actually occurred
and had deliberated for five and a half
minutes on whether pettigrew should be
placed in southern or
gryffindor when peter was sorted into
gryffindor he was overjoyed
and it was in gryffindor that he was
able to make friends with the marauders
however whether he was a proper fit for
gryffindor or not is unclear
as later in life he exhibits many traits
that are very unlike a student of
gryffindor
the hat is quite stubborn and maintains
that it has never made a mistake
but in the case of pettigrew i'm not so
sure of that in fact
i don't know where pettigrew actually
fits gryffindor is meant to attract the
courageous which petrogroup
certainly isn't and southern is meant to
attract the ambitious
which i'm not sure petuku was either he
seemed content to be a pawn that served
a greater power
and i guess that is consistent with
dumbledore's previous statement
where he remarked that some of the
original knights of war pergas were
the weak seeking protection other than
pettigrew it certainly looks as though
no death eaters have ever come from
another hogwarts house
and this is only further supported by
hagrid's statements to harry
hagrid is an active member in the order
of the phoenix which means that he's
been quite involved with the war
and i feel that his belief that no dark
wizard or witch had come from a house
other than slytherin
strongly suggest that all the death
eaters he was aware of had been
slytherins
this also suggests that the death eaters
whose houses we are not provided
were probably also slytherins however
this is somewhat contradicted by a
statement that rowling made
in an interview rowling was once asked
why slytherin continues as a house
if it is the primary breeding ground of
evil witches and wizards
her question to this she responds that
death eaters also have connections in
some of the other houses
but there aren't a lot of death eater
children in the other houses are there
you will have people connected with
death eaters in the other houses yeah
absolutely so while she doesn't
explicitly say here that there are
actual fully fledged death eaters in the
other houses she does assert that some
connections
certainly exist this leaves things quite
wide open to interpretation
as it could a mean that death eaters
have historically come from other
hogwarts houses
and that other houses have the capacity
to produce death eaters
or b mean that only connections exist
and that no other hogwarts house
actually has the capacity to produce one
though they are still connected in some
way whatever that means
from rolling statement i'm certainly
leaning more towards option a
and i say this because more often than
not people from the same family
end up in the same house if connections
do in fact exist
i'm going to assume that these are
familial connections which in my opinion
only vastly increases the likelihood
that some of these other houses have
produced
death eaters we aren't ever actually
given the houses of many of the death
eaters
even the name ones marty crouch jr
rookwood
yaxley and raoul are some of the death
eaters whose houses are never mentioned
and this just leaves everything wide
open what do you guys think
have death eaters come from the other
houses as well or just slytherin
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]